okay I have a channel I have a channel
called perfect d i do debate for Islam
you I'm not Sunni I'm not Shia I
converted to Islam what Islam you
convert okay I converted to Quran and
you convert to Quran yeah the teaching
of Allah and and and the teaching of
prophet Muhammad goes in line with the
Quran so you can
follow okay just my question is that
before your question this is
channel here Studio
speak not Studio here you can dictate to
me we got we control this place you
bring a microphone it's
powerful take this we this
place my question is first question yes
so you become a Muslim yes alhamd Allah
how long you been Muslim now so far um I
was 25 now I'm 60 I was 25 you very
young for you've been
18 I was 25 became atheist and then
after nearly 10 years I became
Muslim your question my question is that
there is a had despite
Quran okay and says to Prophet Muhammad
say you just invite you are not
controller over them okay let them
accept or reject
says anyone leave Islam kill him okay so
my question is that do you think that I
should have been killed when I became
opposite first the Islam teach us and
there's no contrib you
mentioned you cannot force someone to
become a Muslim but if you are a Muslim
then you have to follow Allah's law
Allah
said Allah said
okay so the verse you mentioned does not
contradict the law of apostasy so in
Islamic teaching and Islam no no no no
no no no no no no no as a Muslim yes for
example you have to pray all right as a
Muslim is compos you to pray and the
Muslim leader should force you to pray
okay otherwise you got punished okay for
understand that and for example like
this in Britain if you have if you come
under the British uh territory territory
they forc to certain things all right
okay yes they force you but if you're
outside they canot force you okay so
when you are a Muslim mean you submit to
Allah tala then you
because not just statement necessitate
that you single out Allah in all acts of
worship and you have to follow muham so
there is no cont between the two so
therefore yeah therefore I should be
killed are you apostate by the way I was
apostate I said no K you
everyone Why You Now understand what you
still guil
side wait I'm worry about those 25 who
become apostate they get killed I they
don't get the chance and they don't get
the chance to become Muslim they do they
do they do they do they no you don't
know the
law when someone becomes aate not for
anyone by the way okay so the Muslim Le
you got the Islamic scholar judges to
deal with him okay give him chances
prison
def if you put that sword on
their the sword not yet after oh okay
after now just discussion okay
discussion so because when someone
become a post
there's two type of aat someone who
lives Islam and he lives between him and
Allah and he lives noral life and
someone who start in Muslim country
doing openly then this person he's going
to cause greater harm okay so for the
sake of protecting the umah from his arm
that Allah legislated the Cy to
punishment for example in this country
and in in around the world when uh
covid-19 came about the European
countries and many countries came to
agreement anyone put a video or speak
about covid-19 in in opposition to who
organization World Health Organization
you should put it down and put him in
prison why I put him in prison and put
it down because now they're looking at
okay that's freedom of speech okay but
if if his a freedom of speech is going
to cause a greater harm by given
misinformation and people be killed
therefore we have to shut him down for
the sake of the greater benefit so if
someone leave Islam between him and
Allah there no one cares about him but
if you do openly now then you are
looking for troubles you want to be okay
so you mean that okay no
no all right then you mean
okay then you mean that I should have
been killed yes why you talking about
yourself I don't understand you because
I was an apostate and I was 10 years
apostate okay my my yes so alhamdulillah
you say alhamdulillah don't you Muslim
by the way cuz I'm doubting you cuz the
way talk about
this complete complete complete Quan is
presed yeah preserved word by word word
by word and letter by letter and letter
by letter yes but there is a that says
two vers of quan was eaten by a
goat first this this
is first
is what does he mean weak weak and
offensive so it means that there is a
possibility that it is
authentic said not your studio our
studio
okay Allah protect the Muslim from the
evil and the pl the plot of the ra and
and the enem
Islam who ibraim